الاعلان عن الهدنه الاولى لاربعه وعشرين
ساعه جاء بعد اربعه ايام من اندلاع القتال
بين الجيش والدعم السريع لكن الهدنه التي
جاءت بعد اتصالات امريكيه ونداءات دوليه
سرعان منهارت بعد دقائق فقط من دخولها حيز
التنفيذ في اليوم التالي اعلنت الاليه
الثلاثيه المكونه من الاتحاد الافريقي
ومنظمه الايجاد والامم المتحده ان طرفي
الصراع اعلن التزامهما بتنفيذ وقف اطلاق
نار لمده 24 ساعه لكنها شهدت ايضا اتهامات
متبادله من الطرفين بخرقها في العشرين من
ابريل اعلن كل من الجيش والدعم السريع
موافقتهما على دعوه الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش للالتزام بهدنه
لثلاثه ايام بمناسبه عيد الفطر والتي شهدت
كسابقاتها خروقات متقطعه من الطرفين في
اليوم العاشر للقتال اعلن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انتون بلينكن موافقه الطرفين
النزاع بعد اتصالات مكثفه على وقف لاطلاق
النار لاثنتين وسبعين ساعه ادت الى فتره
هدوء وجيزه سمحت بتسريع عمليات اجلاء
الدبلوماسيين والرعايه الاجانب قبل ان
تشهد بدورها اتهامات متبادله بين الجيش
والدعم السريع بخرقها في السابع والعشرين
من ابريل اعلن الطرفان موافقتهما على
تمديد الهدنه 72 ساعه جديده بعد مساء
دوليه قادتها الولايات المتحده لكن وبعد
فتره هدوء قصيره تجددت الاشتباكات بين
الطرفين لا سيما في العاصمه الخرطوم